Herkese merhaba sizlerle bugün burada
olmak benim için büyük bir zevk
Özellikle de gençlerin böyle bir daveti
olunca böyle bir etkinlik konusunda
hemen Tabii ki gelmeyi çok arzu ettim
bugün ben sizlere iyi şirket iklim için
yeni bir ticaret kanunu konusunda
konuşacağım
Bugün senin gücün ne yazdığımız iyi
şirket kitabında yer alan tespit ve
önerileri sizlerle paylaşmaya
çalışacağım
gezegende insanların da içinde olduğu
hayvanlar bitkiler
mantarlar bakteriler sadece yaşamıyorlar
başka şeyler de var bilmiyorum hiç fark
ettiniz mi aramızdalar biraz böyle
Alaaddin'in Sihirli lambasından çıkmış
gibi cin gibiler Yani bunlar ne Bunlar
tüzel kişilikler ne gibi tüzel
kişilikler mesela dernekler var Vakıflar
var Kooperatifler var Bunlar birer tüzel
kişilik ve bu tüzel kişilikler Çoğu da
faydalı güzel kişilikler ama başka cin
gibiler var ki bunların çok faydalı
olduğunu söyleyemeyiz mesela şirketler
var holdingler var bunlara baktığımız
zaman bunların toplumsal ve ekolojik
açıdan çok ciddi zararları olabildiğini
görüyoruz büyüme ve karmaksimizasyonu
peşinde koşan büyüme ve kar hırsıyla
gezegenin yaşanmaz kılan bu şirketlere
Biz kanunlarla var olma Hakk ını
tanımışız Hatta onların kar etmelerine
dahi zorunlu kılmışız
şimdi Tabii ekonomik sistemin ana
araçları şirketler ve bu geri dönülmez
noktaya yani iklim krizine karşı bu
Onların da çok ciddi bir tutum aldığını
ne yazık ki bugün söyleyemeyiz
dünyamızdaki Biyolojik çeşitlilik
1970'lere kıyasla bugüne geldiğimizde
görüyoruz ki yüzde yetmiş oranında
azalmış Peki Gayri safi milli hasılanın
yüzde kaçını biyolojik çeşitliliği
korumaya ve onarmaya harcıyoruz dersiniz
binde birini
şimdi tabi varlıklarıyla
varlıklarına kanunlarla müsaade
ettiğimiz Ford'un 500 denilen şirketler
var duymuşsunuzdur en büyük şirketler bu
şirketlerin ilginçtir yüzde seksen üçü
iklime dair hedefler koymuşlar kendiler
ine ama ne oldu geçen her yıl Biz daha
fazla sera gazı sağladık ve Ne oldu Bu
hedeflere diye merak ediyorum doğrusu
baktığımız zaman 2022 yılı içinde
küresel karbondioksit emisyonları 2021
yılına göre yani bir yıl öncesine göre
yüzde bir buçuk artmış
2020 yılına göre ise
%7.9 arttıklarını görüyoruz şimdi bu
kabul edilmez bir rakam düşündüğünüzde
Çünkü bu bir buçuk dereceye ulaşmak için
geri kalan
bütçemizin yani karbon bütçemizin yüzde
7 ila
%36'sını tüketmiş olduğumuz anlamına
geliyor Yani biz 2022 yılı içerisinde
31.6 giga ton
karbondioksitleştiği almışız Şimdi bu ne
demek yüzde 67 olasılıkla Biz önümüzdeki
iki ila 7 yıl içerisinde bir buçuk
santigrat derece yaşayacağız demektir
şimdi buna baktığımız zaman
bunun temelinde ne var Bu salınların
şirketler var
arabanı yapan şirket
benzini satın aldığın yer şirket benzini
rafine eden yer şirket
rafineriye petrolü çıkartıp ulaştıran
şirket
Peki onların var olma hakkını sağlayan
ne kanun
peki Nasıl oldu da biz İnsan ve diğer
hayvanlardan gayrı bu genellikle zararlı
tüzel kişiliklere izin verdik kanun
nezdinde onları tanıdık bir de haklar
verdik
şimdi isterseniz biraz nostaljik olalım
birlikte ve geçmişe gidelim bu Başta
böyle değildi şirketler böyle değildi
geçmişte
kimilerine göre şirketi icat eden Roma
hukukçuları
modern şirketin en eski öncüsü olarak
milattan önce 500
yıl sosyal hatasız kıble canarım denilen
devlet Kiracıları topluluğu diye bir şey
var onu kabul ediyorlar iki şirketlerden
bu tüzel kişilikler 11 ve 13 yüzyıl
arasında yine Roma hukukunda belediyeler
üniversiteler
kolejler ve loncalar şeklinde şehir
bazlı
ihtiyaçlarılarla birlikte ortaya çıkmış
tüzel kişilikler Niye Çünkü mülk sahibi
olmaları gerekiyor yönetim kurmaları
gerekiyor anlaşmazlıkları çözecekler
Bunun gibi pek çok sebepten dolayı bu
tüzel kişilikleri ihtiyaç duyuluyordu
Ama bakın ne Bunlar belediyeler
üniversiteler
kolejler loncalar hepsi kamu yarar
yine bakıyoruz bu tüzel kişiliklerini
ortaya çıkmasına İngiltere'de antik
kasaba ve mahallelerde kraliyetki
çoğunluğu Kraliyet John tarafından tüzel
kişilikler verilmiş bu antik kasaba ve
mahalleleri
Böylece onlara Dava açma ve dava edilme
Hakkı sözleşme yaparken üçüncü bir
kişiye tüzel kişi adına hareket etme
yetkisi veren şirket mührü kullanma
hakkı ebedi var olma hakkı gibi haklar
tanınmış Hani bilirsiniz şirketi adına
bir işlem yapmak isterseniz hep kaşe
isterler ya işte bu o yani ta şeye doğru
antik İngiliz kanunlarına kadar gidiyor
bu kaşe hikayesi
Ama bakın yine kasaba ve mahalle Yani
yine bunların kamu yararı gözeten
kurumlar olduğunu görüyoruz Üstelik
kamusal tüzel kişilikler Yani bu mahalle
ve kasabalar
kraliyete yani mutlakiyete karşı bir güç
olarak da kamu yararına hizmet etmiş o
dönemde parlamentoyu güçlendirmiş
hükümdarların gücünü kısıtlamış Şimdi
geldik nereden nereye ne gibi tüzel
kişilikler var
Almanya Yani esasında Prusya demek lazım
1794 tarihinde Rusya eyaletleri için bir
genel arazi hukuku oluşturmuş ticari
ortaklıklardan bahsediliyor burada yani
özel izinli kurumlar denilen tüzel
kişilikler ama enteresandır bu özel
kişiliklere var olma hakkı sadece ve
sadece
kamuya faydalı olduklarını göstermeleri
kaydıyla veriliyor sen şirketleşmek
istiyorsun diyorlar ki Senin faydan ne
kardeşim ispatta bize ancak öyle
toplumsal fayda Temelli kurulabiliyorlar
o dönemde
şimdi Tabii gelelim Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri Beyaz Adam oraya ayak
basmadan önce Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde Amerikan yerlileri ortak
kaynakları sömürmeden gayet güzel
kullanacak kadar bilgi ileride
kullandıkları ekonomik yapı ise
müşterekler ve hatta bugünkü
müştereklerin Kolektif yönetimi
dediğimiz
21 yüzyılda çıkan hareketlere çok benzer
yapılar şeklinde ortaya çıkıyor
müşterekler şeklinde yönetiliyorlar
tabii
kapitalizmin Kalesi dediğimiz Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri diye düşünürüz değil
mi Ama Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nin
18 yüzyılda Avrupa'daki sömürden kaçan
göçmenler tarafından kurulduğunu
unutmamamız lazım ama göçmenlerin
belirli değerleri varmış o dönemde
bu değerler nedeniyle Kar amacı gütmeyen
şirketler Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde başlangıçta uzun bir süre
boyunca var olmuşlar 150 yıl öncesine
kadar neredeyse Bu şirketlerin tamamı
Kar amacı gütmeyen topluma fayda
sağlamak üzere kurulmuş şirketlermiş
Hatta TOKİ ile o zaman da
oradan geçip bir kitap yazdı Amerika'ya
dair orada da hayretler içerisinde diyor
ya burada müthiş şirketler
diyor o dönemde kar ayıp
çalışmanın üretmenin amacı topluma
faydalı olmak kendine fayda yaratmaksa
ayıp kar amacıyla hareket eden
şirketlere karşı da çok büyük bir
güvensizlik var
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde
toplumsal değerler dayanışma ve kamu
yararı anlayışına sahip o dönemde
iyilik ve hayırseverlik Temelli bu
sosyal Paradigma önemli Niye Çünkü
sosyal itibar ve etkiyi güçlü kılıyor
Sonuçta bunlar bizim çok da yabancı
olmadığımız değerler biliyorsunuz bizde
de zenginlik göstermek Ayıptır
Zenginliğin varsa Hayır işlersin
verirsin ve zenginliğini paylaşırsın
varsa param Hayır yapmazsan sana böyle
şey gözüyle bakarlar Hatta biliyorsunuz
siyasetçilerde de yerli arabaya binen
başbakanlarımız vardı veya sade vatandaş
gibi yaşayan şey trafik ışığında Duran
insanlar vardı değil mi bu ülkede İşte
bu değerler esasında aynı değerler
kökünde yatan bu tip ahlaki değerlerden
bahsediyoruz zaman içerisinde bu
Paradigma büyük değişiklik gösterdi
iyilik ve hayırseverliğin yerine para
kar ve 1811'den itibaren sınırlı
sorumluluk dediğimiz şirketler kavramın
büyümesine bıraktı
İşte bu sınırlı sömürü sınırlı
sorumluluk bu kar hırsı kar için
sömürünün
normalleştirilmesinde ve Kanunlara dahil
edilmesinde en büyük
sorumlular sömürge şirketleri mutlaka
duymuşsunuzdur birleşik Doğu Hindistan
şirketi İngiliz Doğu Hindistan şirketi
Fransa Doğu Hindistan şirketi hatsın Bey
şirketi Kanada'da etkili olan ve
aynı zamanda Hani İtalya Osmanlı
arasında kurulan Levent şirketi gibi
Bir de Emperyalist ve devlet vari haklar
verilmiş bu şirketlere Öyle ki askeri
birlik kurabiliyorlar Savaş
başlatabiliyorlar keyfi yasa koyuyorlar
uyguluyorlar bunları yerel halkı
köleleştiriyorlar satıyorlar bu
imtiyazlı
sömürge şirketleri bugünkü şirketlerin
temeli
bugün bildiğimiz kanıksadığımız şirket
kavramının ortaya çıkışında milyonlarca
insanı öldü acı çekti ve istismara
uğradı
sömürge şirketleri ve kullandıkları
yöntemler 19 yüzyılın sonunda değişiklik
gösterdi tarihsel gelişmelerle
karmaksimizasyonunu piyasa kontrolü ile
elde ederek sağlamayı amaçlayan büyük
şirketler oluşmaya başladı
ve 19 yüzyılda Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde iktisadi gücün büyük
şirketler tarafından kontrol edilmesi
ekonomik bir sorun olmanın yanı sıra
toplumsal da bir sorun haline geldi
duymuşsunuzdur mutlaka standart Oil
şirketi gibi karakterleşen bu zararlı
şirketler yıkıcı fiyatlandırma
uygulamalarını kullanarak tekerleşti bu
Tekerler ve tekele yakın kuruluşlara ne
diyoruz traşı
bunlar bunları Yani bu testleri ne
yapacaksın kontrol etmen lazım yasalar
çıkmaya başladı
trust önleme yasaları ile bu Devler
dağıtıldı bir kısmı rekabet yasalarıyla
da dizginlenmeye çalışıldı ki gemi azi
almasın
lar diye ama bunlar geçmişte kalmış
şeyler değil bugün ne baktığımızda
mesela Apple 2013 yılında fiyat
sabitleme ve e-kitap fiyatlarını
yükseltmek için yayıncılarla yatay
Komplo düzenleme suçlarından suçlu
bulundu
Facebook Instagram WhatsApp'ı satın
alarak sosyal medya sektörünün büyük
çoğunluğunu tekerleştirdi ve sonra Mete
oldu
mefta değil Meta Amazon'da bundan farklı
davranmadı Google
1999'da ilk mühendislerinden Amit
patelin ortaya attığı etik çerçeve yani
nedir Don't bir Evil kötülük yapma
motosuyla yola çıktı Sonra bunu
değiştirdi Hatta ne yaptı do the right
doğru olanı yap diye
ama Google sahip olduğu gücü Piyasayı
Manipüle etmek kullandığı
Manipüle etmek rekabeti yok etmek ve
tüketicilere zarar vermek için
kullandığı suçlamasıyla soruşturma
altına alındı ve 2021'de Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri hükümeti tarafından
Google'a karşı 4 anti trust davası
açıldı
Bunlar sadece Amerika'da olmuyor benzer
durumları Bugün Türkiye'de
e-ticaret sektöründe de aynı şekilde
görüyoruz Bu konuda Füsun Nebi'nin
yazdığı nefis yazılar var mutlaka
okumanızı tavsiye ederim Füsun ne
bileyim
mevcut Ticaret hukukunun tek amacı daha
fazla kar elde etmek olan ve bu amacına
ulaşmak için hem doğayı hem de toplumun
sömüren cansız ama ölümsüz bir varlığın
mevcudiyetine meşrulaştırması son derece
korkutuyor
hedefleyen sınırlı sorumluluğa sahip
şirketlerin bu karanlık geçmişi hem
insanlar hem de gezegen için büyük
acılara neden oldu halen de sorumlusu
oldukları iklim ve Biyolojik çeşitlilik
krizi de devam ediyor bu gerçek Ne oldu
Tabii ki insanları yine harekete geçirdi
iyileştirme çalışmalarına yol açtı
hepimizin bildiği kurumsal sosyal
sorumluluk kavramı ortaya çıktı
yine aynı şekilde Bu çerçevede kirleten
öder diye bir
ekonomik politika aracı olan üreten öder
prensibi uygulanmaya başlandı ardından
çokça gündeme gelen değer bazlı yaklaşım
ortaya çıktı şirketlerin
davranışlarını değiştirmek üzere sonra
daha Radikal eleştirilerde başladı
küçülme hareketi diggro olsa
duymuşsunuzdur dayanışma ekonomisi
müşterekler çıktı
sorumlu ve misyon odaklı şirketler için
artık bir toplumsal talep var Ve bunun
da artması ile Fransa'da 2019'da yeni
bir yasa çıkarıldı
yeni bir tüzel kişilik sosyete amisyon
bu tüzel kişilik Öncelikle işinin sosyal
ve çevresel etkilerine dikkate almakla
yükümlü
sonra varlık nedenini tanımlaması
gerekiyor
ve sosyal ve çevresel hedefleri şirket
tüzüğüne yazma ve gidişatını izlemek
için de özel bir komite kurması
gerekiyor
bu ve bunun gibi işletmeler de biz bir
araya getiriyoruz bir ekosistem
oluşturuyoruz sonra o şirketleri Bu
forma doğru evrilecek şekilde üretim
tüketim değil türetim ekonomisi diye bir
şey kuruyoruz ve bütün bu şirketleri bir
araya getirerek topluca yardımlaşarak
dayanışarak öyle bir varlığa doğru
evriltmeye
ancak hala şirketler biliyorsunuz karbon
salonlarını arttırmaya devam ediyor ve
iklim acil durumu derinleşirken
Biyolojik çeşitlilik krizi de
gezegenimizi fakirleştiriyor
daha köklü ve Derinden bir değişime
ihtiyacımız var Bu böyle devam etmez
bunun için ekonominin aktörleri olan
şirketleri topluma ve doğaya faydalı
hale getirmekten Başka çaremiz yok
şirketlere karşı artık mücadele etmek
zorunda bırakılmamalıyız
Ben niye sürekli şirketlere karşı
mücadele etmek zorunda olayım
bunun artık hukuki olarak çözülmesi
şirketlerin hukuki olarak islah edilmesi
gerekiyor
bunun için yeni şirket yasası Peki neye
benzeyebilir ne yapmamız lazım
bir istisna olan sosyete amisyonu değil
bir kural olarak sosyete emisyonu hayata
geçirmemiz gerekiyor
Türk şirketler hukukuna bakarsak ki
dünyadaki bütün şirketler hukuklarına
bakmış olursunuz Türk Ticaret hukukuna
bakarsanız Çünkü hansman ve katman diye
iki araştırmacı var bakmışlar şirketler
kanunlarında tarihin sonunu görmüşler
hepsi benzeşmiş şu anda Dünyanın
neresine giderseniz gidin
şirket hukukunun evrimi bugün anlattığım
gibi ilk aşamalarda ağırlıklı olarak
toplum için iyilik yaklaşımıyla başladı
daha sonra kontrolden çıkmış bir yapı ve
anlayışla kanser gibi tüm dünyaya
yayıldı günümüzde de farklı gibi görünen
şirketler kanunları esasında bütün
ülkelerde benziyor
bu homojenitasyon nedeniyle senin
gücünle önerdiğimiz yasanın genel
ilkeleri tüm ülkelerin
yasalarına ve uluslararası yasalar
içinde uyarlanabilir şimdi ne öneriyoruz
Türk Ticaret Kanunu için madde 331
şirketler
gezegenin ve insanının faydası olmak
koşuluyla yasalarca yasaklanmayan
herhangi bir ekonomik amaç için
kurulabilir şeklinde değiştirilmesi
gerekiyor madde 339 Bent 2 esas
sözleşmeye aşağıdaki hususlar yazılması
gerekiyor CHP şirketin gezegene ve
insana nasıl faydalı olduğuna ilişkin
özel Amaç
tabi gezegene ve insanlara fayda sağlama
amacının ifadesi tek başına yeterli
değil aynı zamanda bu yararım nasıl
olacağı şirketin tüzel kişilik olması
hakkını verenler tarafından halka da
kanıtlanması gerekiyor tabii ki
bu ne onun için de madde 397 içinde
şöyle yazılması gerekiyor ekolojik ve
sosyal beyanlara uyumlu olup olmadığı ve
gerçeği yansıtıp yansıtmadığı da denetim
kapsamı içindedir şeklinde değişmesi
gerekiyor Yani bütün şirketlerin
gerçekten buna uymadıkları Aynen nasıl
mali denetime uğruyorsa şirketler
ekolojik ve sosyal fayda denetimine de
uğramaları gerekiyor
ve tabii madde 529
gezegene ve insana fayda sağlama amacına
uymayan bu amaca Uyumsuz davranan veya
bu amaca uyması imkansız olan şirket
veya dernekler varlık nedenini
kaybedebilir Dolayısıyla feshedilebilir
net
yok mu yararın topluma ve doğaya bay bay
firmaların amaçlarına yönelik Bu
koşulların da eklenmesinin ardından
şirketin ekolojik ve sosyal etkilerinin
raporlanması ölçülmesini içeren denetim
standartlarının Tabii ki oluşacağını
öngörüyoruz bu değişiklik aynı zamanda
şeffaflık ve izlenenin birlikte
geçirerek gezegene ve topluma fayda
sağlayacaktır burada mali denetim yapan
arkadaşlarımız varsa size bir iş daha
çıktı onu söyleyebilirim
böyle bir köklü değişiklik size bugün
imkansız gibi görünebilir
Ancak şu anda önümüzde çok önemli bir
fırsat penceresi var bu değişikliği
Zorlayacak 3 nokta var
birincisi bugünkü iklim ve Biyolojik
çeşitlilik krizi altında ekonominin iş
ve finansın sürdürülemez oluşu İkincisi
ise ülkeler politika oluştururken
şirketleri Zorlayacak gerekli özel
kanunların ortaya çıkışı devam etmeyecek
ekonomi böyle mecburuz yani Farklı bir
şirket anlayışı ile gitmeye bu yönde de
kanunlar ortaya çıktı ama üçüncüsü
gençlerin
sivil toplum kuruluşlarının Hatta
hükümetlerin başka şirketlerin insan ve
doğa Hakkı ihlalleri çerçevesinde açılan
davalarda çok yüklü tazminatlara mahkum
edilmeli
iflas edecekler yani hukuki açıdan
dolayısıyla böyle bir hukuki değişimin
mutlaka gelmesi gerekiyor Onun için
önerdiğimiz değişiklik esasında sadece
rasyonel değil
sosyolojik açıdan da gelmekte olan
onun için diyorum ki Gelin hep birlikte
gelmekte olanı hızlandıralım ve bu
şirketleri islah edelim
topluma doğaya faydalı haline getirelim
teşekkürler
[Alkış]